[Music]
i'm now more than 230 miles west of the
fortress of jiu-guan
we're here in the kumtag desert it's one
of the harshest environments i've ever
been in my life
you know very little grows here the
temperatures are
literally below freezing
it's a hell of a place to imagine
finding archaeology
sarah's guiding me to faint traces of
what looks like an even older wall
that she spotted on the satellite data
[Music]
if i get up here i think i can get my
first glimpse
[Music]
wow this is cool and it's not exactly
what i expected
and it looks kind of primitive
want to see more like get up closer
here in the middle of nowhere a stretch
of ancient wall
and it looks very different from
anything i've seen so far
[Music]
this is a very distinctive kind of
material
we have rammed earth packed down
with a reed foundation these are reeds
this is actually a you know a type of
thick grass
pressed in there to serve as a
foundation to hold the wall stable
this framework is an ingenious way of
building even with the desert's loose
sand and gravel
but if the ming didn't build this then
who did
to find out i'm meeting jiang joon min
the head of a team from the gansu
institute of relics and archaeology
who are digging for answers
well this is so cool tell me what you
have here
these are two arrowheads we found nearby
one is bronze and one is iron
you can see it's still sharp i've never
seen
this shape to an arrowhead before you
know where it's
it's basically three-sided like this and
it is
is that common we found lots of these
along the wall in this area
these arrowheads are very typical of the
han dynasty
[Music]
1500 years before the ming
before the roman empire formed in the
west
and cleopatra ruled ancient egypt
the han dynasty rose to power
[Music]
they oversaw a golden age of art
culture and economic prosperity
they're so well preserved i'm just
amazed look at that edge
it's just incredible the form is just so
clear and beautiful these tiny
arrowheads reveal something momentous
that the wall here is more than two
thousand years old
it's an even earlier great wall of china
that once stretched for over 6 000 miles
much of the famous ming dynasty wall was
simply built right on top
fifteen hundred years later
battered by desert winds for over two
millennia
what remains of this ancient stretch of
great wall
are just fragments of what was once a
mighty
barrier it's kind of hard just looking
at these ruined sections of the wall
to get a sense of what it looked like
originally so using historical sources
and archaeological evidence we've made
this pretty phenomenal digital
reconstruction of what the wall
might have looked like it's just amazing
when it was first built the wall would
have stood up to 20 feet high
this thing was enormous can only imagine
being part of a
an invading nomad army and coming up
against this wall
and thinking you know maybe it's better
to just go home because
this was formidable
[Music]
you